HAVE A QUORUM HOPEFULLY AS SOON
AS WE ESTABLISH THAT WE THINK
GO.
SURE LACKEY FOR FORTHCOMING.
SIGNATURE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE LAST MONTH IS EGGMAN PRESENT
FROM THE MONTH THIS EGGMAN
PRESIDENT.
PATTERSON.
BURKE.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER PRESENT LACKEY.
HERE LACKEY PRESENT MEDINA.
MEDINA PRESIDENT QUICKSILVER.
WE HAVE A QUORUM OUR FIRST BILL
UP FOR THE DAY WILL BE MISTER
STONE.
WHO ATTRACTED?
WORLDWIDE OPPOSITION.
MINTY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH ADAM CHAIR
AND THANKS TO YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL AND AMENDING IT I
THINK WE'VE REMOVED A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION INSTEAD OF THE SAP.
SO A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO THE
LEGISLATURE.
HAD ESTABLISHED FOR THE
PARCHMENT PUBLIC HEALTH THAT
TAXPAYER FUNDED GRANTS THAT GO
OUT TO RESEARCH BE THEN BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
AT NO CHARGE BECAUSE IT'S
TAXPAYER FUNDED BASICALLY
PUBLICLY FUNDED.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS APPLY
THAT SAME STANDARD ACROSS THE
BOARD TO ALL STATE AGENTS?
AND SO AFTER WITH IF THIS BILL
GOES INTO EFFECT AFTER TWELVE
MONTHS THEN.
THAT THEY WOULD NOT GIVE A
CHARGE FOR THAT RESEARCH IT
WOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE FOR FREE
TO THE PUBLIC AND AGAIN PUBLICLY
FUNDED. RESEARCH SHOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE AS SOON AS PRACTICABLE
OUT TO THE. TAXPAYING PUBLIC AND
IN ANYONE WHO WANTS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT RESEARCH
THAT'S THE POINT OF THE BILL AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THAT YOUNG COUPLE
WITNESSES TO. TALK ABOUT THE
BENEFITS AND APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT.
GIVEN THE BOOZE IN MOAB MOVING
SECOND IT DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE COULD.
CERTAINLY I THOUGHT YOUR TELL
MOTHERS EGGMAN UP BY SHARE
PATTERSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S ERNESTO
FALCONE I'M THE LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL FOR THE ELECTRONIC
IS THAT WE ARE A A LEAN
NONPROFIT FOR CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND WE HAVE OVER FOUR ONE
THOUSAND DUES PAYING MEMBERS.
MANY OF THEM HERE CALIFORNIA AND
WE FOCUS ON POLICIES THAT
BENEFIT THE USERS AND CREATORS
OF TECHNOLOGY.
I IN THE WORDS OF SIR ISAAC
NEWTON AND I HAVE SEEN FURTHER
BECAUSE I STOOD ON THE SHOULDERS
OF GIANTS.
ACCESS TO PASS INFORMATION
FUNDAMENTALLY ADVANCES THE
PROGRESS OF KNOWLEDGE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE'S
LEGISLATION WOULD ALLOW OUR
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
PLAY A PIVOTAL ROLE. IN
ADVANCING KNOWLEDGE.
THE PREMISE IS SIMPLE ENSURE
THAT TAXPAYER FUNDED RESEARCH
KNOWLEDGE THAT IS GENERATED BY
OUR COLLECTIVE INVESTMENT ACT AS
CALIFORNIANS IS DISSEMINATED FOR
THE BENEFIT OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
IN THE WORLD.
THE OUTCOME OF THIS POLICY IS
IMMEASURABLE.
WHEN GOVERNMENT USED THEIR POWER
TO ADVANCE KNOWLEDGE OF ALL
RESEARCHERS AND FALL ONE USERS.
IT ADVANCES EVERYONE TO SEE
FURTHER.
THE SAME COULD BE SAID OF THE
REVERSE TOO MANY RESTRAINTS ARE
RENTS APPLY TO INFORMATION CAN
HAVE TRAGIC RESULTS.
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE.
MALARIA RESEARCHER.
BY NAME OF CARDINALS
NOTED THAT WHILE WESTERN
SOCIETIES HAVE MADE ADVANCEMENTS
AND TREATMENT FOR MALARIA SUB
SAHARAN AFRICA WITH LACKEY.
BECAUSE FOR THIS DISPARITY MORE
THAN HALF OF THE REQUISITE
INFORMATION NEEDED FOR THOSE
TREATMENTS WAS BEHIND A PAYWALL.
AND RESEARCHERS AND MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS AND SOME OF THE
MOST IMPOVERISHED NATIONS OF THE
WORLD SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY FOR ACCESS TO THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
ESTABLISHED.
WHEN WE MAKE THIS INFORMATION
FREE TO ACCESS
WE MAKE OF THE ADVANCEMENTS MORE
EFFICIENT AND LOW COST.
TODAY MOST FEDERAL GRANTS FOR
SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH CARE THE
SAME REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL
PROPOSES TODAY.
BUT OTHERS ARE GOING EVEN
FURTHER.
FOR EXAMPLE THE BILL MELINDA
GATES FOUNDATION THEY HAVE OPEN
ACCESS POLICY THAT RESEARCH THEY
PRODUCE IS AVAILABLE THE DAY OF
PUBLICATION THE DAY OF
PUBLICATION.
AND COME INTO THAT SIXTEEN WHEN
SCIENTISTS FIRST OBSERVED
GRAVITATIONAL WAVES CONFIRMING
EINSTEIN'S THEORY OF RELATIVITY.
THEY MERELY PUBLISHED THEIR
FINDINGS IN AN OPEN ACCESS
JOURNAL.
IF I MAKE ONE FINAL POINT ABOUT
THE BENEFITS OF OPEN ACT OPEN
ACCESS TO KNOWLEDGE AND THE
BENEFITS IT IT PROVIDES.
THE INTERNET AS WE KNOW
CONNECTS EVERY PERSON WHO AND
GIVES EVERYONE THE ABILITY TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS THAT WE WERE
PRESENTED. SOMETIMES RESOLVING
THESE PROBLEMS JUST REQUIRE A A
NEW PERSPECTIVE IN A FRESH ANNA
AND FRESH SET OF EYES.
I TAKE JACK AND DRAKA WHO AT THE
AGE OF SIXTEEN.
RELIED ON FREE ACCESS TO
INFORMATION FROM THE BIOMEDICAL
AND LIFE SCIENCES JOURNAL FROM
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
HEALTH.
AND DEVELOPED A METHOD TO DETECT
A RARE FORM OF CANCER.
JACK IS WHAT IT MEANS TO SEE
FURTHER BY STANDING ON THE
SHOULDERS OF GIANTS
SO IN CONCLUSION IF IT STRONGLY
SUPPORTS AB TWO ONE NINE TWO WE
COMMEND ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE
FOR BEING A LEADER ON THIS
FRONT.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR.
VOTE IN THE FIRM THINK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN.
AS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
A CHAIR VICE CHAIR AND JIMMY
TODAY UNICA'S OUR SCIENTISTS ON
BEHALF OF OUR SIXTY THOUSAND.
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND I
HEAR TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND ITS GOAL OF.
PUBLIC ACCESS TO PUBLICLY FUNDED
RESEARCH.
.
THIS IS DIRECTLY LINED WITH OUR
ORGANIZATION'S MISSION OF
SCIENCE IN FOREIGN POLICY AND
ALSO BROADER GOALS OF SHARING
KNOWLEDGE FOR THE PUBLIC GOOD.
AND TO SAY IT'S A SIMPLY.
SCIENCE IS NOT MEANT TO SIT ON
A SHELF.
NOR IS IT MEANT TO REST IN THE
HANDS OF THE FEW.
AND IF IT'S WORTH FUNDING
RESEARCH WE BELIEVE AND IT'S
WORTH SHARING THE FRUITS OF THAT
LABOR.
AND A PHD CHEMIST A PROBABLY
TRAINED A NEW YEAR'S EVE
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM.
AND I SPEND MOST MY TIME
WORKING ON ISSUES RELATED TO AIR
QUALITY AND CLEAN VEHICLES AND
AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO
ACCESSING THAT SCIENTIFIC
RESEARCH FINDINGS.
FOR PROFESSIONALLY TRAINED.
SCIENTISTS THAT CAN EVALUATE
AND FURTHER SHARE OF THOSE
RESEARCH FINDINGS ABOUT WHAT IT
LET ALONE THE GENERAL PUBLIC
THAT FUNDED. THAT RESEARCH
AND AND SO JUST VOTING THE WAY
IT WORKS TODAY'S INVESTOR
AFFILIATE WITH A LARGE RESEARCH
INSTITUTION.
OR WILLING TO PAY THE TYPICAL
THIRTY FIVE FORTY DOLLARS ACCESS
FEE FOR SINGLE JOURNAL ARTICLE
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THE BULK OF THE SCIENTIFIC
KNOWLEDGE THAT'S OUT THERE. AND
AND THIS IS THE SECOND PROBLEM
AND SO THIS BILL IS REALLY.
ONE THOSE GEMS OF A POLICY THAT.
.
IT'S IT'S NOT SOMETHING ON MANY
PEOPLE'S RADARS NOTS SUPER
FLASHY.
BUT IT IT PUNCHES ABOVE ITS
WEIGHT HAS.
.
OUT OUTSIDE BENEFITS FOR MAYBE
ITS ITS NOTORIETY.
IN THE PUBLIC GOOD.
I THINK THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE TO
BEAR AND OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ITS OF SUPPORT AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN OTHER
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT TODAY.
ANYBODY'S.
EVEREST WE CAN I COMING SUPPORT.
BASEBALL ON BEHALF OF TECHNET IN
SUPPORT.
DALE SHIM STOCK WITH
ASSOCIATION AMERICAN PUBLISHERS
WERE SORT OF AN IN BETWEEN
POSITION OF WE WERE INITIALLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BUT. WITH
APRIL FIFTH AMENDMENTS WE HAVE
REMOVED OUR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IN ORDER TO THANK THE
AUTHOR ON HIS STAFF IN YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAD
AND. WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH ALL OF YOU ON ON THE BILL
AS IT MOVES FORWARD THINKING
VERY MUCH.
A ANYBODY SPEAKING AND IN FULL
UP POSITION TODAY.
OKAY WILL BRING BACK GOT
QUESTIONS
COLLEGE IN THE COMMITTEE.
A I JUST LIKE TO SAY MY LAST FEW
YEARS A DATE. AS UP AS A
UNIVERSITY PROFESSOR AND AND.
ASSIGN ANYMORE TEXTBOOKS AND
ASSIGN STUDENTS TO BE ABLE TO DO
ALL THE READING AND RESEARCH
ONLINE.
SO I THINK THERE'S WAYS THAT WE
CAN DO THAT AND I THINK THIS IS
A GREAT STEP TO BE ABLE TO
EXPAND THAT ACCESS. EVEN MORE TO
THOSE OUTSIDE OF THE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
STONE. THANK YOU AND AND I
APPRECIATE THAT COMMENT.
MATERIALS THAT ARE CREATED BY A
PUBLIC AGENCY IT'S NOT QUITE
THAT SIMPLE BUT ARE OR SHOULD BE
IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN THESE ARE
WHEN WE'RE WHEN THAT THE.
TAXPAYERS ARE ESSENTIALLY
THROUGH AGENCIES GIVING GRANTS
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
BECAUSE IT'S TAXPAYER FUNDED
THAT'S ALSO READILY ACCESSIBLE
THAT'S THE POINT. THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT I'VE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIGNATURE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TH ELEMENT THIS
EGGMAN BY THEM A MONTH EGGMAN
AYE PATTERSON.
BURKE.
BURKE AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY
AYE MEDINA MEDINA I COOK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
IF YOU'RE BUDGET STILL HAVE
BILLS OUT.
A. WE DO HAVE THREE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IF SOMEONE'S
WILLING TO MAKE THAT MOTION.
OKAY SIGNATURE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL IN.
TELL US WHAT WE'RE VOTING ON.
THE FIRST ITEM IS AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN IT'S A DO PASS AND
BE REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THAT MONTH THIS
EGGMAN BY THAT AMOUNT THIS
EGGMAN I'VE PATTERSON.
BURKE
BURKE I FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA QUIRK
SILVA AYE.
YOU VERY MUCH LARGE TO MORE
SORRY PUB AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE IT'S DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET.
BUT A MONTH IS A MAN. ON A MONTH
AS A MAN I PATTERSON.
BURKE BURKE AYE FRAZIER. FRAZIER
AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK
SILVA AYE AND THE LAST ONE IS AB
TWENTY EIGHT.
TWENTY TWO TO PASS A REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
TH ELEMENT THIS EGGMAN BY THE
MOMENT THAT THAT MEANT I
PATTERSON. BURKE.
BURKE AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE
MEDINA. MEDINA AYE QUICKSILVER.
SO I.
DONORS PASSED I SEE WE HAVE
ANOTHER YEAR.
WHICH UP.
WILL BE TODAY PRESENTING AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FOUR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SELL AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FOUR WOULD AMEND THE
PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE.
TO ENSURE THAT THE STANDARDS
USED BY STATE AGENCIES TO
PROCURE NON IT CONTRACTS ALSO
APPLY TO. IT CONTRACTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES OR DID YOU
US HOUSE A GENERAL STATE
CONTRACTING AUTHORITY FOR GOODS
AND SERVICES.
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT ALLOW
AGENCIES TO ENTER INTO LARGE
SCALE NON IT CONTRACTS WITH
VENDORS WHO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
EMPLOYEES. IN THE PROVISION OF
OUR BENEFITS ON THE BASIS OF
THEIR GENDER. OR DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIP STATUS ARE OR WITH
THE VENDORS WHO HAVE LARGE CHAU
TAX DELINQUENCIES AMONG OTHERS.
ALL THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
OR CD T. ARE CURRENTLY SHARES
AUTHORITIES WITH THE GS OVER THE
PROCUREMENT OF IT GOODS
SERVICES.
YET THEY'RE PROCUREMENTS ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THESE RESTRICTIONS
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE
SURE THAT THE SAME POLICIES ARE
HERE TO. NOT JUST IN PRACTICE
BUT AS A MATTER OF LAW. AND THAT
THAT WOULD MAKE SURE THEY ARE AT
HERE TO CONSISTENTLY ACROSS THE
BOARD.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
FOUR WILL ENSURE AN EQUAL
PLAYING FIELD BETWEEN NON IT AND
IT CONTRACTING WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME MAKING SURE THIS THAT THE
STATE IS CONSISTENT HOW. IT
SPENDS UP PUBLIC FUNDS WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
IF YOU'RE MUCH INTEREST EGGMAN
SUPPORT TODAY OF THE SPELL.
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THAT BILLS PROMOTE RANKED
SECOND.
.
AND THAT THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I THINK OWES VERY SUCCINCT IN
ANYTHING OR ALL AND IN FAVOR OF
THE DISK THIS CONCEPT.
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
ALL I ASK FOR ADULTS THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BUT NOT THIS
EGGMAN BY THAT AMOUNT THIS
EGGMAN AYE PATTERSON. BURKE.
BURKE AYE FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE
LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING.
MEDINA MEDINA I COOK SILVA.
SO I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
POSITIVE I SPOKE TOO SOON ABOUT
US ALL BEING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
THIS IDEA. OKAY OKAY NOT WHERE
IT WILL WORK TOWARDS THAT MISTER
LACKEY.
MISTER DALY.
BUT LINE.
I DON'T MIND CRACK.
YOU'RE.
MISTER DALEY PRESENTING AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
TALKING ABOUT SUNSETS IN.
SUNRISE I WAS WARNED THAT
THERE'S SOME ROUGH CUSTOMERS ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
.
THREE YEARS AGO WE THE
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED A
PROGRAM THE LAST STATE EMPLOYEES
REIMBURSEMENT IF THEY USE A
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK COMPANIES
OR SHORT TERM RENTAL. DURING
WORK RELATED TRAVEL.
THE PROVISIONS ARE SET TO EXPIRE
NEXT YEAR. THIS BILL ELIMINATES
AT SUNSET.
AND.
I HAVE A COUPLE OF WITNESSES
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO.
CHIME IN.
PLEASE SECURE MUCH ALRIGHT FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
MR BICU A KEVIN MCKINLEY I
THINK IS FIRST.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DALY CHAIRMAN
VICE CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
KEVIN MCKINLEY.
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS FOR THE
INTERNET ASSOCIATION.
SINCE THE BILL WAS PASSED HOME
THREE YEARS AGO TO ALLOW STATE
WORST UTILIZED SHARING CON
SERVICES.
THE SERVICES HAVE SHOWN TO BE
SAFE RELIABLE ECONOMIC OPTIONS
FOR STATE WE TRAVEL.
IN THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE IS FOUND NO ISSUES WITH
IMPLEMENTATION IN THAT TIME.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT STATE
EMPLOYEES WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THESE OPTIONS AVAILABLE FOR THE
TRAVEL. THANKS.
FOR MUCH.
ALSO GREG HAYES REPRESENTING
AIRBNB.
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
GREG HIS REPRESENTING AIRBNB
AIRBNB HOPEFULLY SOME OF YOU
HAVE USED THAT. OPERATES IN MORE
THAN SIXTY THOUSAND CITIES AND.
THE WORLD HUNDRED NINETY ONE
COUNTRIES ALL BUT THREE. TRIVIA
QUESTION CAN YOU NAME THREE
ANYWAY COST SAVINGS OF FORTY
PERCENT.
OVER HOTELS.
IN MOST CITIES ARE IS ONE OF
THE ADVANTAGES OF AUGUST IN
PLACE TO USE THIS OFTENTIMES
INVENTORIES ARE IMPACTED IN
URBAN AREAS OR IN RURAL AREAS
WHERE MANY EMPLOYEES MUST
TRAVEL.
MY FATHER FOR EXAMPLE FORTY YEAR
VETERAN OF THE DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES.
THERE ARE IS AVAILABILITY WHEN
THERE ISN'T A SOME OTHERWISE AND
LASTLY.
VERY FEW HOTEL CHAINS ARE.
DOMICILED IN THEIR CORPORATE
HEADQUARTERS IN CALIFORNIA THIS
ALLOWS NINETY SEVEN PERCENT OF
ALL THE FUNDS PAID TO GO TO
WELL.
HOST TERRY CALIFORNIA KEEP THE
TAX MONTHS HERE IN THE STATE SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
WILL GONZALEZ A MAP OF UBER I
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE I THINK
OUR SERVICE PROVIDES.
AN OPTION FOR STATE EMPLOYEES
AND ALSO SAVES ON RENTAL CARS
AND PARKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BIGGER MUCH
THIS BILL TODAY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF SOARED U.
S. BEGIN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M LARA SESTO
HERE ON BEHALF OF LEFT AND WE'RE
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MOBILE MOTIONS BEEN.
MOVED AND SECONDED AND I THINK
WE ARE ALL PROBABLY.
USES OF SOME KIND OF.
UBER LEFT OVER AIRBNB WHERE THE
THREE HOUSES TRIVIA ANSWER.
TODAY.
.
NORTH KOREA IS IT THE FACT ONE
OF THE ACT OR THE BIGGEST.
OKAY WELL THERE WE GO ALRIGHT.
IT'S NOT BE SLUGGISH ZOMBIE
TRAVELING ANYTIME SOON FROGS.
ALRIGHT AND HOW THE NO NO
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT ALRIGHT YOU
KNOW WE LEARN SOMETHING EVERY
DAY HERE YEAH SWITCHER.
EVERYTHING WE DO WE DO WE CAN
THANK YOU YOU HAD TO CLOSE IT
WOULD NOT BE A CLOSE MISTER
TYLER I AM I WILL YES THAT WAS
MY CLOTHES I PREACH OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TH OF THE MONTH
EGGMAN AYE AYE THAN A MONTH IS
EGGMAN AYE PATTERSON. BURKE
BURKE AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE
MEDINA.
MEDINA ICRC SELA.
SILVA I UNANIMOUS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
PERHAPS MADAM CHAIR BY A.
IT WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
FIVE MINUTES FOR MISTER
PATTERSON.
AND THEN WE'LL CALL THIS A A ROW
AND WE WEAR WHILE WE'RE WAITING
WE WILL I HAVE TO GO TO CALL. OF
THE ROLL FOR SOME THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FROM THE BILL'S.
AND MATT MADAM CHAIR.
I I HAD A FEW ITEMS THAT I
WANTED TO DISCUSS AND I KNOW
THAT THIS IS TYPICALLY DONE UP
IN. ONE TO ONE BUT SINCE WE ARE
HERE WE HAVE A FEW MINUTES OKAY
DID WANT TO ASK I KNOW WE SPOKE
ABOUT THIS ABOUT OF A POSSIBLE.
EITHER FUTURE FUTURE HEARING OR
EVEN.
LEGISLATIVE ITEMS THAT COULD
LOOK AT ONCE I THINK WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS ONCE LEGISLATION HAS
BEEN MOVED FORWARD. SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR WHAT TYPE OF.
.
ACCOUNTABILITY DO WE HAVE TO
ENSURE THAT THE BILLS ARE
ACTUALLY BEING IMPLEMENTED.
AND HAVE.
IS NOTIFICATION MADE. TO
LEGISLATORS. AND EXAMPLE WOULD
BE. IN TWENTY THIRTEEN I WAS
ABLE TO PASS ON. A BILL FOCUSING
ON HOMELESSNESS THAT WOULD
ALLOW.
.
ADD THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS TO SEEK A VALID
BIRTH CERTIFICATE OR AND A VALID
ID WITH A FEE WAIVER. AT WHICH
WE UNDERSTAND THAT NONPROFITS
ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT BUT THAT
WAS GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED
THROUGH THE DMV AND ALSO THROUGH
THE.
CLERKS
AND.
IT TOOK QUITE A BIT OF EFFORT ON
OUR PART AFTER THE LEGISLATION
WAS PASSED TO ENSURE THEY WERE
ACTUALLY PRACTICING THAT SO. I
THAT'S JUST ONE EXAMPLE.
UP MISTER BRAZIER MADAM CHAIR
AND I THINK SHE SPOT ON WE'VE
HAD ISSUES WITH SOME OF THE
AGENCIES ONCE WE'VE HAD BILLS OF
SIGNED IN PUT INTO.
STATUE AND OTHERS IT SEEMS TO BE
A WAITING OUT HERE THEY TRY TO
WAIT YOU OUT IF THEY DON'T LIKE
IT.
AND SEWED LOVED IT BE HAVING A
HEARING HOW WE CAN HAVE AN
ACCOUNTABILITY COMPONENT. AND
REPORTING AND PERFORMANCE
METRICS THAT ARE DRIVEN OUT OF
THAT AND THAT I THINK IT'S
ESSENTIAL THAT WE. HAVE SOME
KIND OF.
DOCUMENTATION THAT THE HARD
WORK THAT ALL OF US PUT IN AND
OUR STAFF. ACTUALLY DOES GET
IMPLEMENTED GUY I LOVE IT.
AND A HAMSTER WINS BILL WENT
TOWARDS THAT A LITTLE BIT BUT I
BUT I WOULD WHOLEHEARTEDLYAGREE
IN MY. AT AND WE ALL CAME
TOGETHER BUT MY FOR OUR FIRST
YEAR I WANT TO KNOW THE NEXT
YEAR LIKE WHAT HAPPENED WITH
EVERYTHING WE DID LAST YEAR. AND
UNLESS YOU JUST STAY ON IT
PERSONALLY YOURSELF YOU'RE RIGHT
THERE IS NO FEEDBACK MECHANISM
THAT THAT I'M AWARE OF. HOME I
THINK IT'S A GREAT IDEA FOR A
FOR HEARING AND TO BE ABLE TO
GET INTO THANK YOU I'M DIRECTING
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY.
I I I DON'T CHIEF MISTER LACKEY
BUT I THINK THAT SOME WE CAN ALL
GET BEHIND.
NORA.
THE BILL.
I.
WE'RE NOT THAT KIND
I'D LIKE TO CALL THIS MEETING.
TO ADJOURNMENT